she's been a pillar of the fight for
women's rights
and a liberal leader in the u.s now the
death of long-serving supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg
is poised to trigger a significant
political battle just weeks ahead of the
presidential election
even as the 87 year old was dying from
pancreatic cancer
she passed on a plea that there should
be no rush to fill the vacancy
in america's highest legal body al
jazeera's alan fisher
looks at ginsburg's legacy
they started to gather on the steps of
the supreme court in washington as news
of ruth bader ginsburg's death broke
they brought flowers and candles the
numbers swelled
people marking a loss they felt
personally
ruth bader ginsburg was physically small
but her presence loomed large on the
court
she was a blunt talking liberal who
often challenged her conservative
colleagues on the bench
born to jewish immigrants in brooklyn
new york in 1933
ginsburg was a brilliant student she was
one of only nine women to enroll in
harvard university law school in 1956
later transferring to columbia
university where she graduated at the
top of her class
liz ginsberg told one television
interviewer no law firms wanted to hire
a married mother
i had three strikes against me one i was
jewish
two i was a woman but the killer was i
was the mother of a four-year-old child
but as the 60s and 70s launched the
women's movement ginsburg found
a place in academia then as co-founder
of a women's rights project for the
american civil liberties union
she wrote the first supreme court brief
on gender discrimination
after 12 years as an appeals court judge
in washington d.c
president bill clinton appointed
ginsburg to the u.s supreme court in
1993.
ginsburg proved to be a consistent
liberal voice
on the increasingly conservative high
court she supported
abortion rights and gender equality she
also advocated using international laws
to shape u.s laws the outspoken ginsburg
fought several battles with cancer
her dying wish was the vacancy her
passing creates
will not be filled until after the
election
outside the court one trump supporter
with a megaphone urged the president to
move quickly
he was drowned out by the chance of
others the president has already
unveiled a list of people he wants to
put on the court if he wins a second
term
but leaving a rally he only praised
justice ginsburg
she led an amazing life what else can
you say she was an amazing woman
whether you agreed or not she was an
amazing woman
who led an
[Music]
in 2016 justice antonin scalia a
republican choice
passed before the presidential election
the senate refused to confirm a democrat
successor named by president obama
democratic candidate this time around
joe biden says there must be no decision
until the election has passed voters
should pick the president and the
president
should pick the justice for the senate
to consider
this was the position of the republican
senate took in
2016 when there were almost
10 months to go before the election
that's the position the united states
senate must take today
the republican leader in the senate
mitch mcconnell says he will press ahead
with nomination hearings
if given a name by donald trump that is
almost certainly going to happen
now he might not be able to get
confirmation hearings done by the
election in november
but could possibly push them through by
the inauguration in january
and if joe biden wins the election that
could create a constitutional crisis
here
in the united states ginsburg strived to
maintain strong liberal voices on the
supreme court to balance the
conservative ones
now her own voice has been silenced that
balance under threat
alan fisher al-jazeera outside the u.s
supreme court
tribute to coming in across the
political divide
chief justice john roberts announced
ginsburg death
in a statement he said that the u.s has
lost a justice of historic stature
and that the supreme court judges have
lost a cherished colleague
he went on to say that he's confident
future generations will remember
ginsburg
as a tireless and resolute champion of
justice
former u.s secretary of state hillary
clinton whose husband appointed ginsburg
to the supreme court
praised her work and said that there
will never be
another like her former u.s president
george w bush honored the 87 year old
saying that she dedicated much of her
life to the pursuit of justice
and equality and she inspired generation
generations of women and girls
well the makeup of the supreme court
could now take a sharp turn to the
political right
that's because president trump will
likely try to put a conservative
successor in place
even if he doesn't win november's
election the court is made up of nine
members
and up to now has been split 5-4 in the
conservatives favor
chief justice john roberts was appointed
by a republican president but recently
has acted as a swing vote this year
that's helped to secure narrow victories
for the liberals
on issues such as immigration and
abortion rights
appointing another conservative would
tip the balance further right
ahead of upcoming cases on same-sex
adoptions and health care
president trump has already named around
40 candidates to fill
a supreme court scott lucas
is co-founder of america unfiltered a
news analysis site focusing on u.s
politics and foreign policy he joins us
now
from birmingham in the uk scott your
thoughts
on the the death of justice ruth bader
ginsburg and
what it means for the supreme court and
for the country
well first and foremost that tribute to
ruth gator
uh vader ginsburg's legacy that legacy
of upholding and defending rights and
justice
uh as an attorney as a judge
and then as a justice not just on
women's rights although that should be
praised
but on widely civil rights rights in the
workplace
rights in education rights for the
impoverished
the question is what happens to that
legacy
in many ways we have seen this summer in
the united states with anti-racism
marches
those issues of rights and justice that
she's highlighted but what we'll see in
the next few weeks
is the attempt especially by the senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell
hypocritically given that he stood four
years ago for almost a year and blocked
an appointment by barack obama to the
court
he'll say we want to rush this
nomination through
and we know that not that donald trump
will try to
go for someone first and foremost as he
sees not only as a die-hard conservative
but someone that will defend him in the
white house
can they get that justice through by
november the third
because it's not just the prospect of
these important cases that you
highlighted
on abortion on adoption rights on donald
trump's attempt to gut
obamacare if we have a disputed election
with donald trump refusing to leave
office that case may eventually reach
the supreme court
now will there be an additional
conservative judge that will defend
trump
even if he refuses to accept a defeat to
joe biden on november the 3rd
as you say if um mitch mcconnell and the
republicans try to bulldoze of this
a new nomination through the senate
before the election
that would be pretty hypocritical will
that damage
the republican standing ahead of the
election
it's a gamble uh to be honest with you i
don't think mitch mcconnell cares mitch
mcconnell doesn't believe in consistency
i think he's gambling that there will be
enough of an appeal to red meet
republicans that this can galvanize them
to go to the polls on november 3rd not
just for the white house
but in that battle uh to re-elect
senators
because right now republican control is
on a knife edge
but you're quite right it could backfire
in two ways one is it could alienate
uh swing voters who see the hypocrisy
who have not yet decided
if they want to vote for donald trump or
joe biden or democrat or republican in
the senate
but secondly and specifically there are
several republican senators who are
facing
very difficult re-election battles susan
collins of maine for example
is one you're looking at lindsey graham
of south carolina who's the chair of the
senate judiciary committee
now will they support mcconnell's effort
to get a justice through by november the
3rd or given the effect on their
personal chances
will they hold back and thus prevent
mcconnell's political gain
and trying to get the hearings and
confirmation within the next six weeks
and what about president trump's
nominees
for uh the any vacancy on the uh
on the supreme court he's already
approved a number of uh of candidates
just how conservative are they what
difference would
uh con another conservative judge on the
supreme court
make to uh its behavior
they're conservative very very
conservative and really really
conservative there's a couple of
headline names there like senator ted
cruz
senator tom cotton i don't think that's
what you're going to get you're going to
get a judge from the lower ranks
of the federal system and it's not a
guarantee
it's not a guarantee that a trump
appointee will always be conservative
we've seen his first conservative neil
gorsuch vote with the moderates
on certain issues but i think on this
occasion donald trump will go for
someone who's a
real fire breather someone who will go
in and try to shred
for example health care rights that are
in obamacare
that will try to possibly shred economic
rights environmental protections
and possibly go for a supreme court
justice and this will be a big election
issue who will try to help overturn roe
versus wade
which was the key decision almost 50
years ago that guaranteed abortion
rights for women
always good to talk to you scott many
thanks indeed professor scott lucas
there
in birmingham thank you